[Müzik]
İstanbul beyoğlu'ndan bağlandığım için
size bol İnşaat sesleri ve 2 tane kedim
olduğu için kedi sesleri de gelebilir
lütfen konuşmamın bir parçası olarak
görün bu sesleri de Öncelikle bir şey
itiraf etmem gerekiyor sanırım sizden
önce birkaç yıl önce daha doğrusu iki
tane teddeksi lokal ile katılmıştım
çok berbat sunumlar yapmıştım Çok
heyecanlanmıştım her şey birbirine
karışmıştı işte çok büyük bir konuşma
yapacağını zannedip hazla baskı
yapmıştım üstüme Ve sonunda bir karar
almıştım bir daha hiç tedx konuşmasına
katılmayacağımı düşünüyordum Sonra
sizden de ait geldi ve Aslında Korkma ve
düşle teması yerine başka bir temada
davet almış olsaydım sizden kibarca
reddedecektim ve katılmayacaktım fakat o
Korkma
korkmamak üzerine Hatta bir davet olunca
bunu bir işaret olarak gördüm ve
sizlerle buluşmaya karar verdim
1985 Diyarbakır doğumluyum 20 yaşıma
kadar hatta 21 yaşına kadar fotoğrafçı
olmayı hiç düşünememiştim hiç hayal
etmemiştim hiç planlamamıştım da
Hatta arada sayısal öğrencisi olduğum
için elektrikçi olmaya bile düşündüğüm
zamanlar vardı elektrikçi dediğim
elektrik mühendisi gibi değil baya bir
dükkan açıp ampul kablo falan satmak
istiyordum sonrasında vasat bir lise
sayısal öğrencisi olduğum için işletme
eğitimi Almaya karar verdim hayatının
böyle toparlarım diye düşünmüştüm
sonrasında İstanbul'a taşındım
işletme eğitimine başladım ve 3 yıl
boyunca korkunç başarısızlıklarıma devam
ettim okulda hiçbir sınavdan iyi not
alamıyordum okuldan hiç keyif almıyordum
hiçbir sosyalliğim yoktu ve çok
umutsuzdum çok mutsuzdum kendime karşı
sorumluluğumu yerine getiremiyordum
aileme karşı sorumluluğumu yerine
getiremiyordum dünyaya karşı
sorumluluğunu yerine getiremiyordum
Bunların hepsi üstünde çok büyük bir
baskı oldu Bir sabah Tıpkı filmlerde ki
gibi uyandım ve dedim ki bu kadar
mutsuzluk yeter bir şey yapmam lazım
okula gittim kaydımı sildim
ardından hikaye başlamaya başladı
aslında Çünkü çok ağır Depresyona Girdim
Ne yapacağımı bilmiyorum Bir Kuş olarak
nereye uçmam gerektiğini bilmiyorum Bu
kadar baskı altında derken kendimi daha
çok baskı sokmuşken sağlığım çok
etkilendi ve verem oldu
bir yıla yakın karantinada tedavi gördüm
evde bir odada Ablamın eski odasında
tedavi görüyordum ve kimseyle
görüşemiyordum Dolayısıyla ben bu bir
yıl içinde Bu hastalık sürecinde
kimseyle görüşemediğim için bol bol
Kitap okudum bol bol film izledim müzik
dinledim şiirler okudum
ressamların resimlerini inceledim Hatta
Bu dönemlerde yaşamayan Eski dönemlerde
yaşayan sanatçıları kendi arkadaşım gibi
hissediyordum o kadar çok onların
eserlerine
odaklanmıştım ki ve onlarla o kadar çok
hayat bulmaya çalışıyordum ki onları
arkadaşım olarak görüyordum
sonra bir gün internette Google'da
gezinirken
d&r bu sitesinde Bir fotoğrafçının
fotoğraflarını denk geldim
dünyadaki dayatılmış
güzellik baskısının tam karşısında duran
fotoğraflar çektiğini gördüm Bu kadın ve
bir anda ne kadar büyülü ve ne kadar
güçlü olduğunu fark ettim fotoğrafların
ve fotoğraflarda bunların nasıl
anlatılabildiğini araştırmaya başladım
kadının hayatını inceledim çok tutkulu
fotoğraf için hayatını bırakıyor
varlıklı ailesini bırakıyor yani
çocuğunu bırakıyor Düzenli bir hayatı
var Her şeyini bırakıyor sonra fark
ettim ki ben de bu fotoğraf
büyüsünün içinde bulmuşum kendime bir
yandan ekranı düzelttim çok özür dilerim
her gün
otoportu üzerine çalışmaya başladım önce
ressamların otoportilerin çalıştım sonra
fotoğrafçıların otoport ile mi otoport
ödedim selfie değil Bu arada Çünkü o
zaman selfi daha sözlüğe girmemişti ve
zaman ayarlayıcı ile çekilen
fotoğraflardan bahsediyorum size
her gün kendi fotoğraflarımı ilaç
saatlerinde kalkıp zaman ayarlayacağız
Ben aslında bir yıl boyunca kendi
fotoğraflarımı bir odanın içinde
çekerken farklı zaman dilimlerinde de
çekerken ışıkla tanışmış oldum ve ışığı
takip eder oldum
iyileşmeye başladığını da önem verdi
Anneannem rahmetli Londra'da yaşıyordu
onlar Kıbrıslı Annem Kıbrıslı ve
savaştan sonra Londra'ya taşınmışlardı
beni yanına çağırdı ve dedi ki
oraya gidip onun yanında kendi yolumu
bulmam gerektiğini söyledi hiçbir şey
bilmiyordum ne yapacağımı bilmiyordum
hala bu bir yıllık bütün otoportilerimi
bir dosya haline getirdim
ve hikayesini yazdım ve Londra'ya
gitmeden önce orada internetten yine
araştırdım bulduğum bir üniversite
programına Bir de Medya akademisine
başvurdum ikisinden de burslu kabul
aldım üstünde bir ay sonra orada
fotoğraf öğrencisi olarak yaşamaya
başladı ikinci ayımda bir anda
başlamıştı 2 ayımda
öğretmenim Otello müzik öğretmeni
otella beni yanına çağırdı ve
filmlerdeki gibi dedi ki sende bir ışık
görüyorum asistanım
ikinci ayımda Londra'da Londra
piyasasında çalışan bir fotoğrafçıya
dönüşmüştüm hem asistanlık yapıyorum Hem
üstüne görevler veriliyor fotoğrafçı
olarak da gönderiyorum
dönüp baktığımda Bunların hepsine ben o
dönemlerde
fotoğrafçı büyük fotoğrafçı olmayı ya da
büyük fotoğraflar çekmeyi ya da Büyük
başarılar elde etmeyi ülkemde bilinen
bir fotoğrafçı olmayı dünyada
başarılılar elde etmiş dünyada ülkesini
temsil eden fotoğrafçı olmayı hiç hayal
etmedim hayal ettiğim şeyler başkaydı
düşlediğim şeyler başkaydı güzel şeyler
hayal ettim güzel günler olacağını her
şeyin yoluna gireceğini sağlığımı
düzeleceğini kendi yoluma bulabileceğini
O bahsettiğim kuş olarak doğru yolu
bulabileceğime En azından da söylemiştim
dünya tarihinde fotoğraf tarihinde
düzenlenen ilk uzay sergisini bir
fotoğrafın seçildi ve Orada sergilendi
aslında Ondan sonra fark ettim Ben Evet
korkmadım
başarmamaktan korkmadım fotoğrafçı
olamamaktan korkmadım
sorumluluklarımı yerine getirememekten
korkmadım o hastalık döneminde en
önemlisi ölmekten korkmadım Aslında ben
dönüp bugüne baktığımızda geldiğinizde
Hepimizin bir sürü kaygısı olduğunu
biliyorum bir günümüz bir günümü
tutmuyordur belki Mesela dün ben çok
korkunç bir gün geçirdim nasıl
yapacağımı nasıl konuşacağımı bile
bilmiyordum Bildiğim her şeyi unuturum
diye düşünüyordum Dün gerçekten tatsız
bir gündü benim için Ama Bugün sizlerle
buluştuğum için biliyorum ki
nacizane tavsiyem olsun ne olursa olsun
kendinizi kötü hissettiğiniz anda bile
olsa korkmayın ve güzel günlerin
geleceğine En azından inanın Çünkü her
şey çok güzel olacak Çok teşekkür ederim